[Música]
cómo están todos es un gran placer estar
con ustedes aquí como cada viernes como
todos los viernes y para presentarles
este programa a canadá en las américas
café también conocido como el castor
cibernético de sexual jazz de este
viernes 6 de diciembre de mil imágenes
del 2019 del 2019 en vivo y en directo
por facebook live youtube en nuestro
sitio internet y en nuestra aplicación
de la cual les hablaremos más tarde hoy
en el estudio me acompañan luis labor de
leonardo si - bienvenidos y gracias
pablo cómo estás muy bien gracias
y lo que nos están viendo desde allá
pues han visto que tenemos dos invitados
hoy acá en el estudio se trata de flavia
garcía escritora y cantante de tango
bienvenida gracias y profesor de francés
y profesora de francés entre otras
actividades artísticas y allá del otro
lado también está luis zúñiga el autor
del libro tu acento louis no está no
estoy en cámara en este momento pero
luis zúñiga nos va a hablar entre otras
cosas de ese libro y es además fue
nombrado homenajeado
hace tres semanas como uno de los diez
hispanos más
destacar más destacados digamos aquí en
canadá y bueno saludamos también del
otro lado del micrófono y de las cámaras
a todos nuestros escucha veedores que
están en este momento ahí firmes
puntuales como todos los viernes
el castor cibernético de este viernes 6
de diciembre coincide con el trigésimo
aniversario de la masacre de la escuela
politécnica de montreal que ocurrió el 6
de diciembre de 1989 un atentado en el
que 14 mujeres entre 20 años 21 años y
31 años perdieron la vida y diez más
resultaron heridas y catorce y cuatro
hombres entre otros también resultaron
heridos fue un muchacho de 21 años 25
años mark levine quien ese 6 de
diciembre entró en un salón de clases de
la escuela politécnica de montreal y
separó a los hombres y las mujeres
les dijo a las mujeres que eran
feministas y que él detestaba a las
feministas y a partir de ese momento
pues comenzó a disparar en 20 minutos
más tarde 14 mujeres habían perdido la
vida
y 14 personas resultaron heridas también
entre ellas 10 mujeres así que bueno
coincide coincide con este castor
cibernético de hoy 6 de diciembre yo sé
que tú
louis y tú leonardo no habían llegado en
1989 acá yo sé que tú ya estabas aquí
luis de perro
flavia no sé si estaba 19 y a dos
cuadras de la universidad de montreal de
la de la escuela politécnica politècnic
donde ocurrió el evento ya bueno tú como
mujer flavia dinos cómo viviste ese
momento no se supo bien a quién estaba
dirigido el atentado la masacre en el
preciso momento en que ocurría no se
supo
supo más tarde y yo creo coincido con
tan simple
no se quiso decir que era un atentado en
contra de las mujeres en seguidas más
bien se quiso hablar de una persona que
estaba loca que no sabía bien que hacía
que tenía algún problema psiquiátrico
luego con el paso de los años tuvimos
que reconocer que realmente fue un
ataque en contra de las mujeres en
contra del hecho que las mujeres
bueno reivindicaron igualdad en la
sociedad y más clipping atacó
precisamente a un grupo de mujeres que
representaba bien tal vez
el hecho de participar activamente en
una sociedad cómo eran esas mujeres un
cierto estudiantes en politècnic bueno y
por primera vez este año en este
trigésimo aniversario la ciudad de
montreal reconoció justamente lo que
acabas de decir flavia que fue un
feminicidio que fue un ataque
antifeministas y eso se hace 30 años
después
louis tú cómo te cayó esa noticia donde
estabas bueno yo estaba de montreal
justamente yo venía de ganar mis casos
desde octubre que yo había ganado contra
el racismo la discriminación en quebec
contra un movimiento confesional y hoy
en el mes de junio y esta noticia sale
es justamente el 6 de diciembre yo partí
a chile con mi familia para vivir fue
todo lo que estamos haciendo nosotros
trabajando elaborando y construyendo
cuando se sea más justa y más
igualitaria para todos
este hombre venía a destruir todo lo que
habíamos hecho durante tanto tiempo
ahora nadie puede estar
de acuerdo con lo que hizo pero yo creo
que hay que sensibilizar a la sociedad
que las mujeres
forman parte de la sociedad y también
necesitan tener posibilidad igualitaria
a nivel de salario a nivel de empleo y
también son muy discriminadas todas las
mujeres en todas partes y eso es
realmente y espero que ocupen los
puestos que le corresponde
a todos los derechos ahora mismo en
chile hay un movimiento de slam de las
mujeres no es cierto ahora mismo en este
mismo momento que estamos hablando donde
las mujeres bueno han decido salir a la
calle y expresar lo que pasa en méxico
también hay movimiento y se llama la
tesis que son de mujeres que fueron en
el tiempo la dictadura que fueron
torturadas y violadas no ha cambiado en
abuya una conteniendo porque exactamente
lo mismo hoy día en chile se está
viviendo la misma cosa xxi vivió
anteriormente en mujeres que son
violadas torturadas y desaparecidas y
los hombres también maltratan las
mujeres y eso no hay ninguna pena son
protegidos
bien
la mujer no tiene tienen derecho al
trabajo pero será un mínimo menor que lo
inferior a los hombres eso no es justo
todo pueden en américa latina que hace
muchísimo trabajo para que las mujeres
alcancen algo así como una igualdad de
derechos no es cierto pero hay que
empezar por lo más importante que es la
violencia en contra de la mujer que es
inadmisible de hecho y ustedes colegas
hablábamos hoy más temprano pueblo de mi
caso personal en el caso de leonardo no
estábamos ninguno los dos aquí yo llegué
en el año 2004 hace unos cuantos años
después de que esa tragedia ocurrió pero
si la memoria no me falla mente aquí
hablando precisamente con los colegas la
sección con ustedes de ese hecho y lo
que sí recuerdo es cuando me enteré del
caso haber tenido una impresión muy
fuerte porque la imagen que se tiene de
canadá del exterior es que ese tipo de
violencias no ocurren aquí de hecho
ocurren en mucha menor cantidad de lo
que ocurre en otros países del mundo en
el caso de los vecinos más cercanos que
tenemos que es eeuu
bueno ahí son recurrentes
las distintas minorías pero el ente de
ese lo tenés al presidente que maltrata
bueno en el caso específico del
politécnico haberse enterado de un
ataque de esas características en un
ámbito educativo causa una impresión muy
muy fuerte pero evidentemente uno no
estaba aquí no lo vivió como tres
ataques en el ámbito educativo mismo
ante al importante es que fueron luego
de ese fue el de la universidad
concordia con valerie fabricante y luego
kimber bill en el coll estos son ya que
en contra tuvimos tres ataques no en
contra de las mujeres los dos siglos
siguientes pero digamos que el siguiente
fue en contra de colegas
universitarios y el tercero fue en
contra de todo el mundo
que estaba justo ahí exactamente si yo
en él no estaba cuando sucedió y no
tuvimos ahora probablemente se hubiera
sabido por la celeridad de la
comunicación y por las medios sociales y
por cómo viaja la noticia pero si yo mal
no recuerdo fue el primer año que estuve
aquí en el 2002 que escuché esto que es
lo que había pasado y a mí me resultó
raro o sea lo relacionado directamente
porque hoy algún día una de mis hermanas
en el cumpleaños y embasó está digamos
lo tengo bastante presente a la fecha
como tal pero lo que me llamó la
atención fue que en aquel momento cuando
yo llegué si porque fueron cierta
cantidad de mujeres que decidieron los
bosques fueron asesinadas en este en
este ataque
y yo lo primero que pensé fue un ataque
contra la mujer y en aquel momento en el
2002 hasta ese momento no se hablaba de
que era un ataque estrictamente o sea
nunca se hablaba hasta ahora que acepte
que se reconoce oficialmente pero ahora
se reconoce se habla un par de años
después ya empecé a escuchar las voces
de gente que lo tomaban como okupa qué
es lo que pasó acá efectivamente fue
bien dirigido
[Música]
y bueno esta persona asesinó a sangre
fría a estas mujeres que lo que hacen es
marcar una historia a sangre y fuego
bien en mi caso pues ya en el 1989 ya yo
llevaba 14 años viviendo aquí yo llegué
en el 75 ese 6 de diciembre bueno yo
había regresado a los estudios después
de haberlos abandonados los que había
comenzado en argentina y me metí por
otra por a estudiar algo muy distinto a
lo que estudiaba en argentina estuve en
comunicaciones y era el fin de la sesión
si en el 6 de diciembre de la misma
forma en que las chicas que murieron y
que perdieron la vida y todos los que se
encontraban en la universidad en ese
momento estaban preparando sus exámenes
de fin de año y todo lo demás yo estaba
preparando en casa mi trabajo que tenía
que presentar en el marco de la maestría
en comunicación que estaba haciendo en
ese momento y bueno
comenzó la noticia
en la tele en la radio y al principio
fue todo un poco confuso si no pues
sabía como tú lo decías ahorita no se
sabía exactamente qué estaba pasando a
medida que iba pasando el tiempo te
diste me di cuenta de que era gravísimo
lo que había sucedido y es como pensar
que eso estaba sucediendo aquí en
montreal en la ciudad donde yo estaba
viviendo porque bueno cuando tú hablas
de violencia en algunos países desde el
sur del mundo no es tan difícil creer
que actos violentos se reduzcan pero
aquí en montreal pues a mí y eso me
desorientó y me impactó mucho y sobre
todo saber después que las muertes eran
exclusivamente de mujeres se había
atentado directamente contra la vida de
esas 14 mujeres y bueno pues se fue fue
duro
con el tiempo pues uno termina
pasando a otra cosa pero la historia fue
trágica y si no la vi
claro y ahora con mucho el movimiento
después del movimiento y después de todo
toda esta reivindicación y de darse
cuenta que nuestras sociedades son
absolutamente patriarcales y hay que
cambiarlo y darte dar bueno en el caso
canadiense donde se le da a un espacio
más importante alabar a la mujer ni
siquiera es más importante es una ciudad
es más importante que un sitio u otro
fuera la más importante es el lugar como
estado justo el lugar que corresponde de
correos es ahora esta masacre ocurrida
en el año 89 tiene una una esencia mucho
más profunda no aparte de haberlo
reconocido como un feminicidio tiene una
esencia especial porque en esta oleada
de darnos cuenta lo que pasa entonces
esto toma un nuevo tinte y nos da como
esto fue lo que pasó y ahí nos vamos a
tratar de cambiar un poco la cocina en
el ámbito literario tenemos que
reconocer que las mujeres siguen sin
estar presentes en su en la medida en
que deberían y hemos visto recientemente
con el caso del premio nobel que se le
dio a una mujer pero también a un hombre
excel bueno entonces digo no es ya causa
un poco de risa porque no se le puede
dar no sé no entiendo aparte si vemos la
lista de premios premios nobel las
mujeres está subrepresentada pero
increíblemente no creo que hay cuatro o
cinco si hay un par de siglos atrás
todavía si por ejemplo en la lista de la
comisión derecho de la persona ve
realmente la discriminación que con
respecto a las mujeres y de mujeres de
la misma edad que ve que ese inmigrante
vela los salarios son inferiores
a nivel d
de trabajo también son inferiores para
poner la capacidad o sea a todo nivel se
ve que hay en combinación con respecto a
la mujer y sobre todo sobre todo que
quien quiere que es la sociedad más
tolerante y la más abierta del mundo
imagínate tú los otros países
es mucho trabajo hay mucho de que hablar
este tema es seguro pero también vamos a
tocar otros temas por eso están ustedes
acá pero amar el leonardo bueno esa fue
nuestra humilde manera de rendir
homenaje a estas 14 mujeres que
perdieron la vida ese día si alguien los
seguimos y tenemos en saludos y buenos
comentarios en realidad javier gonzález
nunca hará ahí nuestro querido amigo
desde méxico dice saludos al moderador
pablo buenos barrios luis laborda leonor
que menos de los invitados de hoy que
son escritores los 12 dice los invito a
la feria internacional del libro que se
está celebrando esta semana en
guadalajara méxico así que estaría bueno
que tuve una vez hace muchos años
cubriendo la feria internacional del
libro en guadalajara la vestí quebec fue
el invitado de honor
y ese es una de las ferias más grandes
del mundo con la de alemania tenemos que
proponer una misión
estuvimos todos juntos a edad
a relatar la feria del libro alarcón
otra de nuestras top fun dice bueno
poder decir que algo ha cambiado al
menos este terrible hecho puede ser
visibilizados como un femicidio y ahí
tenemos a otro día discutimos miriam el
feminicidio y femicidio hay una cuestión
legal de por medio aquí la lohan
lo han reconocido como feminicidio no es
el acto violento contra la mujer sino es
el acto
contra el grupo de presión y socialmente
condenado por el digamos por el estado
hay una cuestión legal entre femicidio y
feminicidios ahí vamos a tratar de
dilucidar la es decir la micro violencia
cotidiana lleva finalmente a que algunos
atenten contra la vida de nosotras la
sociedad tiene que cambiar gracias por
hablar del tema
es un placer miriam y es un placer que
también colabore con nosotros con tu
comentario muy bien entonces continuamos
y ahora vamos a entrar de lleno con
nuestros invitados yo creo que tú les
dejastes música de donde con la boca a
ver si pueden poner un poco la música
para comenzar del otro lado
na
[Música]
es la gente
con la bandera en el balcón eres tú
quien canta
para que los que estén allá del otro
lado vayan sabiendo que soy la autora de
las letras entonces es gente de mi
ciudad si ellos cuando dice es la gente
de mi ciudad
almaty ciudad de sal refiriendo bueno yo
evidentemente pienso en la gente de
buenos aires y en la de montreal tal vez
más en la de montreal que en la de
buenos aires porque ahora estoy viviendo
aquí pero como tengo dos polos
identitarios muy fuertes que son buenos
aires y montreal bueno pienso en esa
gente este tema que estábamos escuchando
es el tema la gente de mi ciudad
justamente y lo que quiero contarle a la
gente es que podemos vivir en paz
podemos vivir de manera armoniosa y
convivir no es cierto
así no tengamos los mismos valores las
mismas religiones porque de últimas eso
es un detalle si lo que importa es el
ser humano
la relación que podemos tener con el ser
humano entonces bueno de eso se trata
esa canción
si algo twist estaba leyendo desea que
el objetivo es renovar el género tango
componiendo música y textos que reflejen
las realidades de los inmigrantes o sea
tú trans pones el tango argentino se
adapta a la realidad que está viviendo
finalmente aquí como inmigrante sí bueno
lo que el tango es una música muy
machista
una música muy machista las letras son
muy machistas en general las letras son
muy machistas
pero obviamente fueron escritas en
épocas reflejan su época la época que
fueron escritas por eso no se les puede
tampoco reprocharnos y hacer lo que son
pero nosotros como creadores podemos
crear otras letras nosotras otras otras
abordar otros temas y usando el tango
como un ritmo de base
con letras que reflejan mucho más
nuestra vida de todos los días y nuestra
realidad social y nuestra época esa es
la idea ese es el desafío y las letras
justamente tratan de inmigración de
desarraigo y de la mezcla de culturas
salame este es este es el lugar ideal
para hablar de mezcla de culturas si las
letras hablan de mezcla de culturas
también lo hacen en las dos lenguas
identitarias que para mí lo son que son
el francés y el español o sea en el
disco tenemos seis temas en francés y
seis en español y los seis temas hablan
de cosas que a nosotros nos interpelan
en el día a día
entonces esos temas pueden tener que ver
con la inmigración con el desarraigo
pero también con la soledad también con
el frío y con todos los temas que nos
pueden interesar aquí en montreal
en nuestras conversaciones entonces
bueno tenemos
y atrás presentado ya en argentina con
este tango
la semana pasada estuvimos y la anterior
estuvimos en argentina justamente
presentando dos shows en bares notables
de buenos aires- auspiciados por varios
notables de buenos aires y el consejo de
artes de canadá para presentarnos
ciertos dos shows en buenos aires es lo
que hicimos la semana pasada y realmente
la gente que está enfrente nuestro
cuando nos escucha cantar en francés la
hora esto es totalmente
fuera de contexto o sea no se lo esperan
pero pienso que estos del francés france
pero digamos que la idea nuestra es este
se escribirá que en el tango claro no
aparte de ser un shock me imagino para
los puristas del tango escuchar tango en
francés que ha estado por una mujer
y con letras que no hablen del pesar de
empezar al olvidado tristeza y evocando
cosas tristes pero también bueno
hablamos de un montón de cosas pero
bueno no sin embargo fíjate que de una
entrevista en la radio en las dos por
cuatro en un programa que se llama 'the
con talento de tango y justamente
quisieron escuchar los temas en francés
y preguntarme de que se trata no la
milonga de paulette bueno a ver de qué
se trata
y bueno tienes paulette
una señora a la que le gusta gastar su
dinero por lo cual hace quiebra cada dos
por tres
conocemos los domingos en el salón
ese recuerdo en padres bailando el tango
es muy bonito bueno yo sin ser argentino
estuve viviendo en mis años mozos en
buenos aires y estaba en un lugar que se
llamaba en aquella época la casa
latinoamericana en gascón y guardia
vieja precisamente en la esquina y había
un grupo de viejos tangueros que se
reunían una vez por semana ahí el grupo
se llamaba farolito y era una noche de
tango pero entonces ahí aprendí no a
bailar porque nunca presenció a bailar
el tango pero aprendí a querer a amar el
tango entonces aprendí
me tangere chiflado en mi pobreza
ese es uno de los de vida varias santa
lorena mujer tu presencia de bacán ha
tocado en el nido fuiste buena con
suerte y yo sé que me has querido como
no quisiste nadie
bueno
flavio la música sé quiénes son tus
músicos bueno yo trabajo con un equipo
de músicos pero fundamentalmente acá el
autor de las músicas es josé maría
gianelli que es no solamente el músico
sino también el director musical no
solamente el compositor la musa del
director musical
y el arreglador acertó de toda esta
música que nosotros estamos brindándole
a la ciudad de montreal
entonces nosotros nos formamos como un
equipo luego con nosotros trabajan
muchísimos músicos que puedo mencionar
como por ejemplo ser grupo para acordeón
leandro ragusa bandoneón silver acnur en
contrabajo
trabajamos con valerio y gimen violón en
violín perdón
luís lópez en percusiones tenemos muchos
músicos con colaboradores y bueno vamos
a seguir conversando contigo de hecho en
el que tenemos ocho músicos que han
participado en el disco y cuando viaja
viaja con todos los músicos claro que no
viajamos con los arreglos en la valija y
bueno y nos vamos allá a la punta de la
mesa con louis tu acento louis a ver si
me ponen la cámara ahora aquí este este
es el libro de luis la primera vez que
nos encontramos y comenzamos a conversar
fue justamente tu acento cuéntanos un
poquitico cómo fue que surgió este
debate por decirlo así sobre el acento
bueno el libro nace luego de un despido
ilegal y discriminatorio de los años
ochentas me despidieron porque yo tenía
un acento cuando hablaba francés en de
centos hispano
era realmente el movimiento que
confeccionar a la época que frenada a la
integración y la diversidad en la
sociedad que me 4 y cuando me
despidieron todo el pueblo que evacuan
los movimientos los organismos en
general todos apoyaron los políticos
porque este este esta institución habían
instaurado entre lado una la mentoría
integrista a nivel de administración en
la cual ha enviado a todos los
inmigrantes a la escuela inglesas
entonces quiero que pasara que mismo en
el año 97 ir contra la ley 101 e incluso
se hacía con el despido envío se
aprovechó el caso para que todos me
apoyaron y yo creé una organización
detrás mío están los sindicatos tal
organismo y ganamos y vencimos el
momento confesional y abrimos el camino
a la diversidad a la integración en el
que vea que el año 80 y yo era
consideran es en ese tiempo el símbolo
alquímico multiétnico
moderno porque había abierto ese camino
ian se separa un poco la discriminación
también fue una batalla política muy
fuerte que apuramos la comisión de
elección a persona acceder al programa
de ser la igualdad los políticos los
discursos se reformarán cosas prácticas
inmediatamente si hay en discusión en
radio televisión y yo pasé durante un
año un año y medio en radio y televisión
explicando el caso porque es un caso
único es muy difícil probar a alguien
que fue despedido porque tiene un acento
si el tribunal que se creó fue
presidente
y aparte de eso en el año 2017 yo
agregué la palabra exenta del
diccionario que me cual de la lengua
francesa
y este caso ha ido ha cruzado fronteras
porque es un caso típico por ejemplo en
francia la gente que viene marsella a
parís a buscar un trabajo no puede
conseguir porque tiene acento de merced
y entonces no tiene el acento la élite
siente y los latinos la misma cosa en
vancouver yo estuve con la presidente de
chile y me decía aquí los haitianos
cuando llaman por teléfono para pedir un
arriendo le dicen que no pero llama un
chileno inmediatamente si tengo un
arriendo aquí de momento que tiene un
acento ya eres discriminado o sea el
acento es un pretexto porque detrás el
acento existe el sexo el color el origen
étnico y la nacionalidad o se vale decir
que es el caso del acento realmente
saurio y hoy día estamos creando un
documental con respecto al acento que
realmente va a salir en los próximos
meses y louis tú tú has peleado con
tanto empeño ese tema del acento que fue
gracias a ese empeño que le pusiste se
agregó al diccionario de la lengua
francesa una nueva palabra que es el
absentismo
eso fue nuevo y en inglés también se
agregó falta en la lengua de española
haciendo los trámites porque en realidad
es una cosa ilegal
enviarla pero también se va a agregar
ahora el ascetismo si realmente la gente
nos había preocupado de este fenómeno
tipo pero y 10 están dando cuenta que es
una cosa discriminatoria muchas personas
por ejemplo un amigo quien que nació
aquí es salvadoreño nació tiene su llama
esto gonzález y lo llamara por un
trabajo y le dijeron que hiciéramos lo
con éstos gonzález si soy yo permitiendo
tiene acento o sea realmente realmente
quiere un acento por el nombre el
apellido o sea entonces son barreras
realmente a la integración a la sociedad
vale decir que beck metro metro yo
encuentro a todos los actores políticos
y le discuto con ellos para sensibilizar
que realmente nosotros son un aporte en
la sociedad no son una amenaza y el
acento es una riqueza cultural pero
incluso cuando se habla de acentos yo no
puedo evitar pensar en que se habla
siempre de acento hacia el extranjero y
eso implica un propio desconocimiento
porque uno
sabe viniendo de la fuera que aquí mismo
hay una variedad de acentos
impresionantes yo cuando llegué a canadá
llegué a la ciudad de cantina que está a
unos 100 kilómetros de aquí es decir no
es el otro lado del mundo y cuando añade
gatineau para aquí
sentía un acento totalmente distinto en
los propios quebequenses que me hablaban
y cuando me mudé a montreal iba a
visitar un amigo que vivía entró a
rivière que también está un poco más de
ciento y pico de kilómetros de aquí
nuevamente no es el otro lado del mundo
es muy cerca y entro rivière el acento
es totalmente distinto al que se usa en
montreal es decir dentro del propio
francés y del francés quebequense hay
una variedad de acentos impresionantes
que ellos mismos no reconocen me dio
igual que sea discriminado por cierto
también a los franceses que vienen de
otros
digamos gente que viene de otros países
que hablan su lengua materna en francés
a franceses de francia que tiene un
acento muy fuerte a franceses de bélgica
a los franceses de la toma grave del
norte de áfrica realmente o sea hay una
variedad extraordinaria de acentos no
solo de acentos extranjeros en cuanto a
habla otra lengua entonces tiene ese
acento
para hacer un problema el problema de la
discriminación que existe con respecto
al acento porque en realidad el acento
es una riqueza cultural y en bingo lo
que se tiene problema en ontario cuando
quieran hablan inglés porque le dicen no
tienen acento porque también se está a
todo nivel
por ejemplo en este caso obviamente
cuando lo hablo francés
y cuando hablo el poco inglés que hablo
tengo un acento se vienen marcados
[Música]
y en el caso del inglés me ha sido menos
complicado estar el anglófono es menos
entre comillas pues suena fuerte pero
menos pretencioso con la pronunciación
exacta el uno le habla a los ponchazos
del inglés el anglófono para tratar de
estos estudios tiene todavía ese tipo de
prejuicios frente a la propia lengua y
eso es un factor que le impide al
francés evolucionar porque obviamente no
excepto si no le permitimos a la gente
hablar francés como quieren como pueden
como saben como el local yo escucho un
chiste muy bonito con respecto a una
llamada por teléfono a una radio
francesa una persona con mucho acento
que no podía decir cuando iba a comprar
pan quería comprar una baguette y la
diferencia entre un uno y uno
y uno en masculino y femenino decía y no
se le encontré una
el presentador de radio pido 2
[Risas]
bueno louis recientemente hablábamos
decíamos ahorita que
honrado como uno de los diez hispanos
más sobresalientes aquí en canadá y
bueno en realidad fíjate para mí
realmente yo no yo no corro detrás de
los premios porque yo realmente lo hago
este trabajo hace 30 años luego por
principio porque creo pero a veces hace
muy bien recibir un premio es la verdad
en realidad el año pasado también
recibió un premio por la personalidad
del año sobre la diversidad en quebec
reconociendo está entre malí de plante
de ni turco de marinos y nidos egipto y
eso también fue un reconocimiento o sea
eso reconoce que realmente es un trabajo
que he hecho durante años y sigo
trabajando en un premio me da más fuerza
para seguir adelante porque hoy día en
toronto puede decir quién me premio yo
lo compartía con todos mis compatriotas
chilenos que estaban luchando por la
democracia y por la libertad de chile y
en realidad la gente me aplaudió de un
aplaudió porque realmente vio que
realmente yo sigo trabajando por no
tanto por los chilenos sino que por todo
los latinoamericanos del mundo porque
todos viven la misma situación sobre
todo los latinoamericanos que sobre todo
aquí en montreal es una comunidad la más
pobre con respecto a los judíos lo árabe
en realidad y hay que ayudar al médico
que lo que colabora con ellos
leonardo comentarios mensajes aquí y
javier gonzález nunca le dijo flavia en
américa latina hay mucho que hacer con
respecto a feminicidios y acoso sexual
es lo que pasa hoy en a méxico dice
carlos gonzález nogueral nelson contra
las rincón dice buenas tardes saludos
desde barranquilla colombia feliz día de
las velitas para todos el día de las
velitas si el 8 de diciembre es la
semana también el día
machista es césar rodríguez charlize y
se salió débil y bogotá no saluda con
acento con acento hispano pero el
francés se ven muy bien
entonces si continuamos acá con nosotros
en estudio
[Música]
quiero poner a ver un poco de
el tiempo corre rápido vamos a pasar con
los temas que queremos resaltar esta
semana y volvemos con nuestros invitados
después tu luis laborda sí señor tú nos
hablas de de el trasplante de órganos
que en canadá a pesar de las campañas
que se han hecho en más de una ocasión
sigue habiendo un faltante de órganos
para transplantes a pesar de que ha
habido también un incremento de la
cantidad de gente que se ofrece a donar
sus órganos y esto se debe a que también
ha aumentado al mismo tiempo la cantidad
de gente que entra en un estadio
terminal de diversas enfermedades por lo
cual la demanda de órganos también ha
crecido con el paso del tiempo en el año
2018 que es el año del que se tienen los
datos más recientes hubo cuatro mil 351
personas que figuraban en la lista de
espera para diversos órganos es decir
una cifra importante si uno toma en
cuenta cuál es la población canadiense
que ronda los 35 millones de personas
y un incremento muy importante en la
cantidad de órganos de personas que
tienen muerte cardiorrespiratoria que es
una de las formas que se utilizan para
determinar la muerte de la persona la
otra es muerte cerebral en ambos casos
ha habido un incremento pero los órganos
necesarios aún siguen faltando y como
último dato porque no tenemos mucho
tiempo digamos que el mayor número de
trasplantes en el año 2018 fue de
riñones con mil 706 casos seguidos de
hígado 533 pulmón 361 corazón 189 y
páncreas 57 a pesar de esas cantidades a
pesar de esos números tan elevados el
faltante sigue existiendo y se invita a
la población a que tome conciencia de la
necesidad de donar órganos no hay que
estar muerto para hacerlos hay órganos
que se pueden donar estando en vida y
que son muy necesarios y muy útiles para
salvarle la vida o para restituir la
salud a personas que están enfermas sí
bueno esto leonardo nos habla de una
manzana
es puede conservarse hasta un año
así es en realidad la historia de la
pregunta porque ahora que estamos con la
tecnología y con vamos con la
inteligencia artificial y las cosas
cuestiones con las computadoras no está
fue este fue un trabajo de 20 años de
mezclarse milita con semillita tipo con
tipo de distintos tipos de manzanas
hasta que lo lograron en este caso se
llama la kozmic chris salió a la venta
la semana pasa en eeuu en
en eeuu si aquí va a llegar
suponen que para otoño del año 2020
tenemos nosotros también podemos
pretender no no no no creo no creo bueno
prestación tiene las cosas que uno
detesta de las manzanas increíble uno
corta la manzana a los 10 minutos se
pone marrón se oxida por esta no se
oxida por ejemplo y uno la puede guardar
heladera durante meses y meses que no se
va a echar a perder son es increíble y
aparte para pensar en el gasto y en el
derroche de cuando uno compró manzanas
mi hijo muerde una manzana deja y está
fea la tiramos no está no se va a poner
fea genéticamente no a eso es otra vez
se han hecho no no no y eso es por eso
no está la tecnología puesta en marcha
sino el trabajo arduo de ir colocando en
realidad fue a la base de la hong y
christ y la enterprise dos tipos de
manzanas una muy brillante muy hermosa y
otra con un gusto particular y fueron
mezclando estas dos tipos de semillas
hasta que salió el árbol después de
cinco mil seis mil diez mil
al escuchar los que no funcionaban uno
que cruzó y que dijo esto es
espectacular y empezaron a empujar para
que esto saliera y efectivamente han
logrado después de 20 años de
investigación a la antigua
esta nueva dos años en la heladera señor
bueno pero yo tengo un peral en mi casa
que compré hace muy poquito
no queda cuatro tipos de peras a cuatro
y cuatro variedades y decíamos no puede
ser no pero si da cuatro variedades de
peras y en cada ramita dice este es el
injerto de tal pena que ya me olvidó los
nombres
bueno paloma martínez no se encuentra
con nosotros en este momento pero ella
los invita a escuchar una entrevista que
hizo con uno
para una compañía canadiense de danza el
espectáculo se llama fronteras y que
hablan no sólo de las fronteras como tal
en general sino también de las fronteras
internas que nosotros mismos nos ponemos
los límites que nosotros nos podemos nos
ponemos digo perdón y personalmente yo
invito a todos los oyentes ya los que
van a estar viendo este programa a
escuchar una entrevista que hice con una
tía con la tía de ay tenemos la imagen
de fronteras y estuve conversando con la
tía de jessica soto fernández
jessica soto fernández que es una madre
de familia chilena que sufre de un
cáncer de tipo linfoma y está
necesitando urgentemente
trasplante un injerto de células madre
entonces se hace un llamado a ella es
chilena y siendo chilena ya se hizo una
primera prueba con respecto a los
familiares que son incompatibles con
ella no son compatibles
el banco d
de células madres de emma quebec tampoco
tiene las células que necesita entonces
se necesita un injerto de células madre
que vengan de latinoamericanos entre 18
y 35 años para poder salvarle la vida a
esta mujer que está luchando muy
valientemente para seguir viviendo ella
es madre de tres niños de tres o de tres
personas ya adultas espero
quiero que lean y que vean y escuchen
ese reportaje y bueno seguimos acá en
estudio con el poco tiempo que nos queda
quizás ya para las últimas palabras con
nuestros invitados presentaciones media
bueno justamente el 11 de diciembre la
semana que viene el día miércoles es el
día internacional del tango estamos
festejando lo en el show de medición del
mundo con un espectáculo donde va a
haber una charla primeramente con
frederic leo está que es músico perdón
es músico etnólogo ue tecnólogo de la
música
músico etnólogo y luego una presentación
en dúo jose maría gianelli piano y yo
misma voz
de algunos tangos tradicionales para
mostrar un poco la evolución del tango
los periodos por los que ha pasado el
tango y también incluiremos algunos de
nuestros temas
entonces 11 de diciembre 19 horas santos
de misión del mundo
quiero decir que el trabajo que hace el
santo de mi visión del mundo es un
trabajo excelente no solo nos da a los
artistas una posibilidad de presentar
nuestro trabajo y poner en evidencia lo
que hacemos sino que también tiene una
vocación pedagógica y social
entonces yo invito a la gente a que se
acerque el 11 de diciembre pueden
comprar las entradas por event bites
bueno abierto con buen tango
bueno estamos preparando el documental
para el 2020 será un documental con
respecto al libro pero la gente ha
pedido ha exigido que es que ahora está
en la época numérica en todos y todos
quieren verla en el clan y eso va a
estar listo esperamos para 2020 antes de
junio para concursar en cierto
festivales de películas
la elección del centro de misiones molde
50-43 el santo mínimo de al asad dt 1 de
1 y es en un primer piso en un salón
precioso que con una acústica muy muy
linda la gente lo va a disfrutar bueno
les recuerdo que los nombres de nuestros
invitados hoy luis zúñiga y flavia
garcía muchísimas gracias por haber
aceptado la invitación de reunirse aquí
y de estar con nosotros estos momentos
gracias gracias y bueno acá en el
estudio que pasó vamos a saludar a la
gente del otro lado
pierre útil también bien pedro el útil
que le dice ella
[Música]
muchísimas gracias y eso fue todo por
este de canadá en las américas de este
viernes 6 de diciembre muchísimas
gracias a todos y bueno hasta la próxima
adiós
[Música]
o sea ya chantal se me olvidó el
apellido